this is the stena empiro a british oil
tanker traveling through the persian
gulf
on july 19 2019 it was on its way to
saudi arabia when it received a radio
message from iranian naval forces
[Music]
zero degrees immediately
later the stena impero was dramatically
boarded and seized
using speed boats and helicopters iran's
revolutionary guard took control of the
british tanker and took it to an iranian
port
the stenempiro isn't alone several oil
tankers have run into trouble in recent
months
already troubled waters were further
roiled with attacks
on two oil tankers three iranian vessels
tried to block a british tanker
an unnamed u.s official is blaming iran
for explosions on four ships iran
declared it has seized an iraqi oil
tanker plot these incidents on a map
and you'll see them centered around this
narrow ocean passage
the strait of hormuz dozens of oil
tankers pass through here daily
each carrying up to 84 million gallons
of oil
this flow of oil represents 20 percent
of the world's supply
a former iranian prime minister even
referred to this passage
as the jugular of the global economy but
these ships and this narrow strip of
ocean
are caught in the middle of a struggle a
struggle between the us
and iran one that has the potential to
escalate
and to choke the global economy in the
process
the strait of hormuz lies between iran
and oman
it links the persian gulf to the gulf of
oman which eventually leads to the
arabian sea
at its narrowest the strait is less than
34 kilometers wide
and oil tankers that pass through here
travel on a pair of
shipping lanes each three kilometers
wide
most of these ships carry petroleum
products from the middle east to the
rest of the world
and in particular to asia but an attack
on any tanker here
regardless of destination can affect the
price of oil everywhere
that's because oil is a globally traded
product a drop in supply from the gulf
can drive up prices from other sources
around the world
after two recent oil tankers were
attacked in the strait of hormuz
the price of oil from the north sea
jumped nearly two dollars per barrel
it's because of this strategic
importance that the strait of hormuz has
become a place where
long simmering tensions between the us
and iran are playing out
and it all began with the tanker war
[Music]
saddam hussein ordered his troops across
the iranian frontier
after a series of border skirmishes war
broke out in the middle east
in 1980 after iraq invaded iran
the us helped iraq and its campaign
against iran by providing military
intelligence behind the scenes
when iraq wasn't able to topple iranian
forces over land
it turned its attention elsewhere
missiles against tankers
are the weapons that both sides are
using to try and break the stalemate in
their war on land
iraq moved to cut off iran's main export
it began attacking tankers carrying oil
from
iranian ports in what became known as
the tanker war
iran eventually responded by attacking
oil tankers moving to
and from the gulf states some of which
were supporting iraq
but with iraq being aided by the west
iran had to get creative
it turned to sea mines and planted them
around the strait of hormuz
for the first time iran was using the
disruption of oil moving through hormuz
as a weapon but these disruptions
finally drew the us
directly into the conflict
in 1987 the u.s stepped in to protect
the flow of oil for itself and its
allies
by escorting tankers tensions between
the two countries began to escalate
in 1988 a u.s naval ship struck an
iranian mine
injuring u.s sailors on board a couple
months later
a u.s warship mistook an iranian
passenger aircraft for
a fighter jet and shot it down over the
strait of hormuz
killing all 290 passengers ronald reagan
has issued a statement deeply regretting
the loss of life
in what he calls a terrible human
tragedy
the iran-iraq war ended in august 1988
but conflict between the u.s and iran
continued for decades
and tensions and distrust grew on both
sides
and a major source of that distrust was
iran's nuclear program
by 2002 suspicions were growing in the
u.s around iran's intentions
by now iran was fighting proxy wars
around the middle east and
the u.s feared an iranian nuclear weapon
could fall into the wrong hands
iran and their terrorist allies
constitute an
axis of evil by seeking weapons of mass
destruction
these regimes pose a grave and growing
danger
there were reports that iran had
expansive and
undisclosed nuclear facilities like this
one in natanz
and this facility in iraq finally in
2011
a un report revealed that iran has
carried out activities relevant to the
development of a nuclear explosive
device
the mutual distress between the u.s and
iran boiled over
they have not found even one gram of
uranium to be diverted to military
purposes
iran has refused to satisfy legitimate
concerns about the nature of its nuclear
program
the u.s announced sweeping sanctions
against iran president obama signed an
executive order that
for the first time specifically targets
iran's petrochemical industry iran's oil
exports dropped dramatically
and with it iran's income the country's
economy began to shrink for the first
time
in nearly a decade to fight back iran
used the only leverage it had
the strait of hormuz
iran threatened to close the passage
saying not a drop of oil will pass
through the strait of hormuz
if iranian oil is sanctioned and to back
its threat
iran's navy conducted a 10-day show of
force in the strait
u.s naval forces followed suit warning
iran that closing the strait
would not be tolerated the threats are
being ramped up over a vital oil
shipping route the chief of
u.s naval operations has told al jazeera
his navy is capable of securing the
strait of hormuz should it need to
the u.s navy and the coast guard ships
two close encounters just last week
the strait of hormuz was once again a
tense conflict zone between
iran and the us but this time the two
countries reached a diplomatic solution
today after two years of negotiations
the united states together with our
international partners
has achieved something that decades of
animosity has not
a comprehensive long-term deal with iran
that will prevent it from obtaining a
nuclear weapon
[Music]
in 2015 iran agreed to scale back its
nuclear program
and to allow its nuclear facilities to
be monitored in exchange for sanctions
relief
with sanctions lifted iran's oil exports
picked back up
and iran's economy showed signs of
recovering
until 2018
i am announcing today that the united
states
will withdraw from the iran
nuclear deal the fact is this was a
horrible one-sided deal that should have
never
ever been made claiming the original
deal with iran didn't go far enough in
addressing iran's terrorist proxy groups
president trump
abandoned the nuclear deal with iran and
put sanctions back in place
[Music]
[Applause]
the ongoing conflict between the two
countries has turned hormuz into a
flashpoint once again
with tensions at levels not seen since
the tinker war
tensions with iran have reached a
boiling point iran
trouble nothing but trouble the united
states is not
interested in diplomacy period president
trump says the military was quote cocked
and loaded
to carry out airstrikes against iran
iran hopes that disrupting the passage
of these international tankers will put
pressure on countries to stick with the
nuclear deal
while also putting pressure on the u.s
to lift sanctions
but without the direct diplomatic
contact between the u.s and iran
each run-in has the risk of escalating
into war
one that could disrupt the jugular of
the global economy in the process
[Music]
you